welcome to this video playing tactical
swallow I really have a terrible score
against the sky minus form although 11
games strange can I do this probably
yeah the double of you and shadow this
is some really solid line there for
black I don't have a particularly great
recipe against that have to say but
white is typically very solid down
after the trade that I want to take on
g2 with the night and then maybe 9335
that's the idea that kind of good I
don't know we can take it or take with
the night okay can take maybe we're
really with the bishop and then 98 okay
probably maybe it's just equal
my night is slightly wrong there only
one it would like to do something with
this is six square but that isn't that
obvious now I don't want to want to want
to trade of course that will do just how
come i mean i can trade it's not it's
not totally bad hmm interesting let's
the looks a bit better yeah that's it's
interesting I think that's it's quite ok
I have Bishop e3 if this can be an
interesting interesting point down to
fight for the C file and I to cyst c6 is
still IDM
yeah 92 and then 94s that that right 92
roxy 594 rook somewhere 96 yep and let's
go for that go straight away for that we
can square I know rube c3
okay i guess i have to to allow 94
if it goes a4 that's an interesting
question do I go before or not hmm or
just 94 94 I guess it takes on b3 a
beard the f are also might be useful for
me to attack it with Luke a one-day porn
not easy for him to play now this is a
this is an important point here that I
saw couple of wolves a goal can be a
tricky business now fan whoa that looks
really really wrong but ok I'm taking
should be at least a pawn I take g6 that
Bishop is six check so I think I should
win upon them
they're in fact probably yes to play
rook takes you one now and whatever it's
a bad position in any case
I don't really see me now 95 takes on g6
and threatening bishop e-cigs so what
the guess I'm just taking and play by
step battles 96 for example it's that
better even though not probably not
let's grab this stuff so we should check
their check then Roxy 7th should be good
rook the 896 flat-out winning I'm
threatening the say yes he has to do
that and now batik is seven king of six
takes on a seven on driving everything
here Jackie yeah maybe just rook f7 and
tending hook f4 it's three points by now
look f4 is not made unfortunately it's
close but you still has d3 Jack adds the
looks like a decent booth but don't win
anymore material here right ma don't I
don't ok can push push stuff here just
TG 6 single night before something here
maybe I can like this actually I'm just
kind of irritated that the game stuck
into last but resign ok so that's all
good i think this position here for
black rot here this is c 6 weakness some
still a problem for him right here i'm
not sure how if he can still equal i
seea that light will come to c6 and well
this one before was necessary and the
engine has already really pessimistic
gives it gives me a winner already
probably they are probably dis that bad
night coming to c 6 i mean there are
three points that will hang and black
really has nothing to show for it he i
went bishop here yeah this is this is
this is just just losing probably Jack
and I could okay this wins but this was
even easy i'm jack that would have would
have forced immediate resignation
okay jack yeah but okay if you have like
four points or three points more here
extra it's okay nothing I'm to criticize
him what went wrong there in out out of
the opening because it's not a really a
super line for wide this this yeah maybe
here maybe here I mean he does not have
to play Queen 85 he can probably even
know even num allow me to take on a
seven I mean something like this I mean
I'm not sure if I can really take it
looks a bit a bit fishy in the Queen
down now maybe he cannot trap it but I
wouldn't I wouldn't have taken that this
is probably not a good idea now I really
have excellent chances to get the night
down the engine actually wants to do it
like that the directly well yeah it's
it's no real way to how is he going to
stop at them not working not working at
all yeah that was decent thanks for
watching